wait before I do this I'm out of you I
have a question yes I just want to make
sure that when you feel me I don't look
like [ __ ] or anyone really creepy or
anything okay cuz I've seen a lot of
reality shows and they make the weirdos
really look extra weird oh he oh no no
we won't be doing that here we just want
to have a straightforward interview with
you okay okay do I look okay I look okay
hi I'm Heather right I am a 38 year old
woman I live in Wrightwood California
this is my cabin has lived in this cabin
for over 10 years now and haven't left
you may ask why Heather why are you
always home well the outside world is
done I mean what you call a hermit my
grandpa invested in stock and Google
years ago and he said I could just live
here and just have fun you might think I
don't do anything but I actually do I
have a lot of activities throughout the
day I like to smell my pillowcase I
think it's really comforting to smell my
hair grease that's one of my favorite
things also I like to pick what hours
outside of my backyard of course I like
to play the piano I mean I pretend I
know it just feels good like I have a
concert here or something I watch a lot
of TV my ferret shows are The Voice
orange is a new black and Drake and Josh
yeah yeah Drake and Josh
Drake and Josh you kids are like my best
friends I love you a drink
it's so hot you're so hot especially
when you sing oh no I think I don't look
that pretty
I'm gonna go prom lipstick okay and I'll
be right back if I did need to get a job
I think I could see myself working at a
pet smart or a pet store cos let's be
honest pets don't judge people people
judge people that's right I see my mouth
drip saliva throughout the day it's like
my mouth knows I don't need a work hard
the great thing about this hat is that
it tells people it tells strangers don't
mess with that lady she's on something
and I won't be raped because no one's
gonna think that this is attractive in
any way